yo what's up what's up what's up
we're live this is youtube and uh
i haven't really done a live video i
don't think ever or for absolutely ages
on youtube
can anyone actually hear me is this live
is this happening
um
i'm not sure i'm not sure if this is on
i don't want to i don't want to speak
for ages if this is not on is this on is
this on are we good are we good are we
good
charlie b says hello that means that
people can hear me richard says it's on
dude
ma ellison good to have you good to have
you lewis edwards great
this is live i just thought you know
what i can't see your life today rather
than
um rather than pre-uploading a video
every single day i'm doing videos
what's up how's it going okay i'm gonna
give you some crazy uh
crazy information on this call are rich
people jerks
are rich people jerks i've done a study
on rich people
i've watched a little study on poor
people and i'm going to be telling you
what my
conclusion is on rich people and poor
people and how they think
they think very very differently so i'm
going to share on this call i can see
what you're all saying though i can see
your comments popping up hussein he says
where are you i'm at home in
beckensfield
just north of london uh is this live or
pre-recorded no this is live tyrone
we're live right now
um so i did a study on rich people and
poor people
would you clash yourself as a rich
person yes i would class myself as very
very rich
says g biz in fact for me to not say i'm
rich would be an insult
um would be an insult to most people
because it would be like false humility
to be like
no i'm not i'm not rich you'll just be
false humility i'm very rich
um i make millions of pounds so i'm rich
however
my study on rich people versus poor
people by the way are rich people jerks
my answer is no they are they are not
they are not jerks
um they can be jerks so can poor people
um
there's no correlation between how nice
you are as a person and how much money
you have you can have a lot of money and
you can be an absolute jerk and you can
have
no money and you could be an absolute
jerk and you can likewise you can have a
lot of money
and be um and be really nice
uh are you rich through big debt says
jack
horry yeah i am i am i am rich through
debt
debt has made me rich uh for sure
uh good debt of course so yeah i am
i really want to go on your course kobe
has messed it up
i know covert is crazy uh we have got a
lot of our training online so
all right what's my study on rich people
vs poor people so
10 things i want to go through real
quick on this live call stick around
till the end
because um because it's going to be
really good
okay i was trying to think of a better
reason why you should stick around till
the end maybe i could give you away
something for free could i give you
something for free
maybe i will maybe i'll give you
something for free um i'm richer than
you
on roblox i've never heard of roblox so
yes
you are uh why are you asking investors
in the castle project why not use your
own money
um i i i most of my property deals i use
i use other people's money uh if i use
my own money for ev for every project
that i did
i mean and it also goes against
everything i teach
um i teach to use other people's money
use the bank's money use investors money
that's my that's my whole strategy
that's my whole property investment
strategy that's what i've always done
and that's what i'll continue to always
do so i don't think there's anything
really strange especially when it's such
a big project that needs
you know needs um a few million pounds
just on the renovation uh it's quite
it's it's kind of
i kind of expected i would have thought
um
all right so ten things number one
poor people and when i say poor people
by the way i'm not just talking
financially you can be rich but not
have loads of money because you can be
rich because you can live a fulfilled
life and you can achieve what you wanted
to
achieve i'm all talking successful
successful people successful people
value their time and they value
other people's time as well whereas poor
people
and unsuccessful people do not value
their time
people will waste their time at that
people someone will be half an hour late
and they're like no problem it's fine
you're half an hour late for me it's not
fine there's a big we got a big problem
in fact if you're half an hour late for
me i'm not gonna be there
um i'm gonna be gone because i value my
time
you won't see me ever washing my own car
never washing my own car because why
would i
want my car when it when i can pay
someone 10 pounds an hour to do it for
me
when my time is more valuable than 10
pounds an hour
you have ever seen me cutting my grass
cutting my front lawn
or my back lawn you won't see me doing
these things
because i value my time poor people
don't value their time
or people just are just like oh you know
it's fine i'll do it it doesn't matter
that you lie
it's all good it's not all good
now number two oh by the way as well
really important
is that i used to be poor
growing up i was poor and these 10
things i'm going to share with you
a lot of the poor minded stuff i would
have done and and
and it was only when i actually
all depends who was watching your car
says roy i value my car that's why i
washed my car
wrong wrong
so you're what you're saying what you're
saying is no one can wash your car
properly only you that's a poor
mentality
because when you start growing a
business and you need to start employing
people
getting staff if you ever want to be
successful and have a big business and
make lots of money
you need you need to start letting go i
i understand what you're saying
you love your car i get it that's fine
but you need to start letting go
and you got to remember the seven
billion people on the planet
to say that no one can wash your car
apart from you is kind of arrogant of
course someone can wash your car
however you know maybe just get someone
good i understand your point but
you want to be wealthy you want to grow
and scale you have to change
um so it was it was only about 10 12
years ago and i was thinking you know
what actually you know what
i want to be rich so i started studying
rich people started studying how they
think
and when i started studying how rich
people think i realized that actually
i think like them then maybe i'll be
wealthy and i believe that what you
think about and how you think
you can choose what you think you can
choose
what how how what you choose to think
it's it's a choice
and that will then lead to how you act
which will then lead to your results
so you can choose to think like a poor
person
or you can choose to think like a
wealthy person so that's kind of why i'm
doing this video to give you guys
uh the uh the knowledge around how to
choose to think
all right next number two poor
people bash rich people
you know it's just like it's so i i
can predict i feel like i'm getting
shouted out but in a good way
says fire um yeah
i mean it's it's definitely well
intended on my on my on my on
on my end so i can tell you know when
i'm looking at youtube comments
and people are saying uh you're you're
uh you're you're a fraud
i know that the person who said that is
very very poor
financially they have no money um
[Music]
okay rue now is arguing with me again
washing my car is one of my hobbies
don't you have a hobby
uh i do have a hobby however it is not
cleaning and washing up
but fair enough listen if you love
watching your car you know i'm not
saying if you wash your car you're broke
i'm just saying
you generally speaking wealthy people
don't do that kind of thing
okay um yeah when i see people
commenting badly on my videos or bashing
rich people in general
when i see people um saying things about
jeff bezos oh he's me a jerk he's making
all this money in the pandemic i'm
thinking
no he's he's not a jerk he's just making
good money
um richard says i'm hugely keen to find
an
investor i'm finding gloucester
uh all right cool wait if anyone's
looking for deals message message
richard
um so yeah
rich people respect other rich people
rich people respect other
rich people poor people will bash
other rich people they'll try and find
an excuse as to why they're succeeding
you know um oh jeff bezos he's he's
he's screwing people over uh no he's
actually as
gerald just said he's actually providing
a really good service to people and
because he's adding so much value to
people that's why he's rich
be under no illusion rich people get
rich
by helping people because they give
people a product or a service that
people
want and if they
didn't people didn't want it then people
wouldn't buy it so they've got something
they've created something that
billions of people or millions of people
want and then they create it and
give it to them and that's how they
become rich
and and and that's always the case and
if it's not the case
if you're rich because you are genuinely
like robbing people or you're
robbing banks or you're scamming people
then you will be put to prison
but if a rich person is rich and they've
been in business a long time and
and they're going about their business i
will always be like
respect even if i don't like them even
if i think they're a bit of a jerk
respect poor people bash rich people
number three poor
people work hard
okay unsuccessful people work really
really hard
um rich people successful people
look really really smart they probably
work hard as well but they
they work smart really important
and honestly i used to think when i was
growing up um
when i was growing up i used to think i
used to think man i i'm gonna work
really hard i'm gonna be okay because
i'm a hard worker
and then i see some of my friends that i
went to school with
they work hard as well they work harder
than me you know they're plasterers and
they're
um they're like working 80 hours a week
driving around they've always got red
eyes you know you see the security
guards when you're going to petrol
station and they've got red eyes they've
been up all night
it'd be offensive to say that they don't
work hard i've been to slums of india
i've been to rural parts of africa
don't tell me that they don't work hard
as offensive
they're hard workers whereas
rich people they work smart
okay so what they do is that they get 10
people working
for them you're going to outwork anybody
if you've got 10 people
tyron security guy with red eyes yeah i
mean honestly they work hard
you've got 10 people working for you
though you're going to outwork anyone
because there's 10 of you
that's called working smart leverage
your money but also leverage your time
and leverage your work ability and
leverage your efforts uh so i can't
remember who it was someone once said
i'd rather um
i'd someone said i would see this person
right here oh i'm gonna go on to him
sir exxon not now taking mickey out of
my man tyrone
um we're gonna get on to that that's a
that's a portrait by the way
okay that's a really that's a really
poor that's a really portrait um
so yeah he said i'd rather i'd rather
have
i'd rather have a hundred people giving
me one percent
than me given a hundred percent you know
so and what about both what about both
what about i'll give 100 i'll have i'll
have 100 people giving me one percent as
well
or 100 people giving me 50 so don't work
hard work smart
next number five poor people choose
they say things like even people
watching this video there are people
there'll be people saying things like
samuel i'd rather just be happy though
i'd rather just be happy
yeah me too as well i'd rather be happy
as well but i i want to be happy and
rich
um it's like people saying
i don't want a big business i just i
just want to focus on my family you know
i just want i just want a family um
i might block this guy this sir exxon
this this troll and people you know
people that's like
oh my gosh censorship censorship
samuel's team are blocking my comments
how dare they block my comments
how dare they you know i want to be able
to say what i want to be able to say
on samuel's page it's like you're a poor
person you know why because you are
entitled
entitled it's one of the traits as well
uh rich people don't expect anything for
free
um poor people want stuff for free you
know they want they want
they want benefits and they want um
they want the government they're like
what can our country give me
what can my country give me no
jeff kennedy says don't ask what your
country can give you
ask what you can give for your country
um
do an interview with coffeezella um
i said you're great but seem angry a lot
i'm not angry okay i'm really not i'm
just i i mean sometimes things make me
angry
but but generally speaking yeah poor
people in fact
entitlement does make me angry you know
people people that are
always asking what they can get what
they can get where they can get what i
get from this marriage
i'm getting married what can i get what
can i get from the government
what can i get from what can i get from
society rich people rich people
do not act like that rich people say
what can i give
what can i give how can i serve um
opinions on ben melo i don't know about
mala but i think he's awesome will you
do an interview with coffee zeller i
don't really know him but
if he reaches out to me probably i'm i'm
usually pretty open and chill
doing interviews with people um
so yeah poor people are entitled rich
people don't expect anything for free
going back to the thing people say i
can't believe you sense of my think well
listen if you go on my page and you're
talking nonsense and spamming people and
distant distant tyrone and being poor
and bro like
if i did that on your page would you
delete it you probably would
you probably would um okay next
um one two three yeah yeah going back to
the choosing thing okay
going back to the choosing thing um
i'd rather be happy i don't need to be
rich i just want to be happy
i just want to be happy um that's like
saying you want an arm would you want a
leg
it's it's both gal it's not rich people
are jerks it's powerful people who are a
jerk
they use their power to keep people poor
so they can be more easily manipulated
yeah i'm not i don't agree i just i i
disagree
um i think i think power power does not
change you power just
exposes you truly if you are a good
person
and then you become powerful you're
gonna it's gonna magnify you and you're
gonna become a
your goodness is gonna be able to be
magnified um
whereas if you are a jerk and then you
get power then that's gonna be magnified
that's my opinion
um so yeah rich people don't choose
which people don't sound i'd rather be
happy that's
both please i want to be happy and rich
i want to build a business and have a
family
i want to be able to give to charity and
spend my time traveling and
i don't want to be a business serious
business person i want both
you know game king what's happening my
friend power corrupts
power does not corrupt power exposes
what corrupts is bad company
bad company you know hanging around
losers makes you a loser one hundred
percent
okay so one two three or five next
number six
notice number five number five number
five is
poor people make excuses
rich people create their own life
and and often as well you'll see poor
people not only making excuses
do you think rich people should pay more
tax no i do not think rich people should
pay more tax
i think rich people pay a lot of tax and
um
i don't think they should pay more taxes
um
i think that rich people usually rich
people don't pay much tax
that's only because they that's a whole
i could do a whole i could do a whole
video about that
the reason rich people don't pay much
tax is because
they do things like
claim things back so i will rarely
buy things that i cannot claim back as
tax deductible like this t-shirt
this teacher does not cost very much
money i don't know how much it costs but
it's not too expensive
and the reason is because it's not tax
deductible um
i paid a lot of tax last year i paid
over the last 18 months
um i must have paid close to a million
pounds in tax
i did public i did publish um recently
but i pay i've had a lot of tax i want
to start paying less tax
i don't i don't think much people should
pay more tax no um
so yeah poor people make excuses they'll
say oh it's because of
it's because of the tax changes well i'm
not successful it's because of the
government
it's because of my parents my parents
didn't didn't um didn't raise me well
whereas rich people everyone they
weren't they won't come up with excuses
they'll just find solutions more people
tear people down
poor people poor people think
competitively whereas rich people think
collaboratively
poor people will say that person's
winning oh my gosh he's winning
oh my gosh i went to school with him and
he's winning if he's winning
i mean that means he's taking from me
somehow so i'll tear this person down
whereas people think like that rich
people think that person's winning
awesome wow he's doing well maybe we can
collaborate
um poor people will see someone driving
uh a fancy car and they'll be like i
mean honestly it's just terrible i was
with my friend yesterday
she's got a massive big lamborghini and
and
most people are just just just looking
just look at people driving
fancy cars with just staying they're
just like
who do they think they are but i know
someone that scoffs
someone sees me driving a fancy car and
i see him going like oh
like that i know that person is just
very very poor
rich people don't act like that rich
people build people up
rich people want to see people winning
rich people know the whole philosophy of
um your your success is my success
um just looking at these comments
interest only versus repayment mortgage
random ups
i would say interest only is better i
would say interest only is better
all right next poor people complain all
the time whereas rich people see the
best in people
rich people see the best in the
situation and if a rich person doesn't
like something they'll just change it
they don't talk about it they'll just
change it
because poor people love to complain
about it poor people
complain about stuff even stuff like oh
no
my tv show got cancelled and they'll be
all upset about it complaining about it
rich people don't do that rich people
just just see the best or they'll just
say actually you know what that's really
bad and someone needs to do something
about it
i'll do something about it next
entire thing did i do entitlement
already entitlement already
poor people are entitled they want
everything different they just expect
things for free
they expect they want rich people to pay
more taxes why
so that the government will then have
more money to give them
i mean our twist is that you
should pay more taxes and be
forced to give that to the government so
that the government can give it to me
that's messed up how about you just go
make some money
how about you just going to sell some
deals rather than waiting for rich
people to end up paying more taxes
and then they get all upset they get all
upset when rich people are creative
when rich people find loopholes and i
don't get
frustrated a rich person finds a tax
loophole as long as they're not stealing
from the government if they find attack
a tax loophole
um and they pay less tax i'm like great
good for you
awesome now that means you've got more
money to employ more staff
now that means you've got more money to
be able to boost the economy and make
the economy better
um rich people can afford a tissue to
what their nose is
um if you wasn't doing property what
would you be doing
um it's hard to know because i
absolutely adore property
um but because i am doing property
um i got to buy to let's gonna sell my
residence
uh that sounds like a q a sunday
question see me on see me on sunday see
me on sunday
all right next number eight i'm not
paranoid not to rub my nose
our joint ventures worth it yeah 100 100
um i keep getting this question asked
over and over and over again so i guess
that means do i have answer it
uh is it easy to increase your portfolio
if it's already
like one million yeah of course it's
easy to increase it
100 our freedom of right is vanishing
through this scam demick
and we are talking about getting rich
just saying um
yeah you know what i i am i am going to
continue to create my own economy so you
can talk
there's always big problems going on in
the world there
there's there's always massive problems
going on in the world and you can
you sometimes you just have to say you
know what i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
sleep in the storm
and i'm just gonna focus on what i can
control rather than focusing what i
can't control
so yeah there's a lot of messed up stuff
going on like great um
the pandemic is is messed up whichever
way you look at it
if you think that the if you think that
virus is is real
and if you think that it's a genuine
virus and the government are doing a
great job trying to restrict the
spreading um okay cool but you will
still agree that it's a messed up
situation and if you think that it's all
a big scam
and it's all it's all it's all um you
know a hoax
for the government to be able to get
they want and to be able to control
people
um then that's also that's also messed
up but the thing is
we have very little control over that
and
my opinion is that we should just focus
on what we can control
and right now i'm focusing on my
business i'm focusing on my family i'm
focusing on my staff i'm focusing on my
students i'm focusing on my properties
i'm focusing on my tenants
i'm focusing on my customers i'm
focusing on my happiness i'm focusing on
my peace of mind and my spirituality and
my fitness and
my my bank my money like i'm just
focusing on i'm just continuing to focus
on what i
can control um but yeah i agree it's
messed up
and i i i agree that there's something
um fishy going on
and the media and the government 100
they were always
um they will all always always try and
try and scare people to then control
people
and there's a lot of nonsense being said
at the moment why the range rover
because i like i just like it
i just like it um okay anyway
number eight unsuccessful people
spend their money on junk okay they just
spend their money on junk whereas
wealthy people invest their money in
themselves and it's something that's
going to give them passive income
at why did you buy your first property
and how much was it
my first house i was 17 years old it was
a normally downhill
next this one's going to offend some
people okay there's 108 people on the
call right now i believe
uh this one is going to offend some
people
poor people this is only in my
experience poor people and unsuccessful
people
love money
whereas rich people use money
now listen i'm not saying that every
single um every single poor person loves
money
but generally speaking you know what
it's really funny because i was
i was scared to start making lots of
money because i didn't want to fall in
love with it i didn't want to fall in
love with money
and i was i don't want to make too much
but then what i realized was actually
a lot of people that i knew who were
broke
i've got an itchy nose i'm sorry about
that folks a lot of people that were
broke
no money actually loved money they're
obsessed with it
they'd always be talking about money
they'd be going to all the shops trying
to save money
they'd be they'd be scratching those
scratch cards you know
there we go all gone all out there
they've been scratching scratch cards
you know trying to trying to try to
trying to win the lottery
their parents would die and leave the
the two siblings
um some money 20 grand and they'll be
arguing over every penny
so i'm thinking actually loving money
doesn't mean having money
it's a very different thing and a lot of
people that have got no money
they actually they actually love it
whereas rich people use money but i
don't think i don't think a lot i don't
i i i do not love money i like money i
love what money can do
but i actually love money less right now
than i ever have and the reason is is
because
you know when you get a big pizza you've
got a big pizza
and you're really hungry you love that
pizza you look
the moment that you love the pizza most
is when it first comes and you're like
oh
yes and that first bite i love this and
then people come over they're like come
i have a piece
can i have a piece and you're like no
it's mine but then actually what happens
is
once you have a few pieces you begin to
you're not so hungry anymore
you've got half a pizza left you know
it's all right come on tuck in everybody
and you're more generous and in the same
way i think that financially
when you haven't got much money and
you're broke sometimes you're like
what every penny whatever you know you
really want money
but then actually when you've got money
you're a bit more generous and you're
just kind of like actually
yeah it's cool man come another piece
it's all good come and have a piece um
so i i i think that rich people use
money and poor people often often often
love it
why the range rover why not a fast car
like a porsche or a bentley okay firstly
the range rover is fast
it's very fast but i like the range
rover because because the range rover is
comfy and it massages me while i drive
and i have a fridge in there and
everything it's just bigger nice i don't
i don't care about
um i don't really care about what what
people think i'm not i don't care about
showing off
anything i just live my life and do what
i want and if
no if if no one else was on the planet
and i had to just drive around
i'd drive a nice big range rover that
massaged me while i was driving so why
would i drive something different now
just because people can see it um it's a
nice guy it's an expensive
car it's worth over a hundred thousand
pounds but i don't need a lamborghini
i mean geez my car my car's more
expensive than a lot of lamborghinis
people buy like a secondhand lamborghini
and put a private plate on it and drive
it around
feeling feeling feeling all rich and
stuff i'm good
i'm good um all right last
last last one last one
did a lot of people from your past come
out of the woodwork befriending
and asking for money when you first
publicly started being seen as wealthy
um yes some people did do that
not many people but there was some but
there was also some a lot of friends
that actually began
um trying to tear me down you know
so there was there was i lost some
friends as well
and it it can be it can be challenging i
could do a whole new video about some of
the hardships that come with money
but yeah what are your thoughts about
the problems children of wealthy parents
face as a wealthy father yourself
great question um one b i think
my thoughts about that are t you got to
teach your kids
um basically how to everything i'm
teaching you right now is what i'm going
to teach my kids
because being rich your kids could end
up with a poor mindset they could be
entitled they could complain
they could invest their money in junk
instead of investing in themselves
they could love money they could um
bash rich people even
they could not value that or all of
these things i think i think it's a case
of not spoiling not spoiling your kids
teaching them to make money rather than
just exp letting them just become
dependent
i mean i'm gonna make my kids pay tax
i've got two kids they're gonna be
paying tax
um and they're gonna i'm not gonna give
them any money
but i'm gonna give them opportunities
and i'm gonna give them education
great question all right number 10.
number 10 is
is unsuccessful people value
entertainment
whereas rich people value education
you see i will honestly be like
my wife will ask you watch a movie and
i'm thinking
i'll be looking at the the the the cover
and i'll be thinking what am i going to
what am i going to learn
you know what am i going to learn and
it's a sound i struggle to read a
fiction book because i'm thinking if i'm
going to sit down and read a book i want
to read the book i'm going to learn
now there's nothing wrong with
entertainment don't get me wrong but i
find that poor people are always just
wanting to be entertained
they just want to get they just want to
get back and watch netflix pass the time
and escape
into someone else's world i've got
enough i've got enough stories and drama
and entertainment going on in my
everyday life
you know i don't need to escape i just
want to learn
so that i can i can i can have a more
productive life
and i can i can be more and i think that
education is so important um i consider
myself an educator
maybe an entertainer as well but i
consider myself an educator and i just
i just read like these we can see some
of these books these these are
all these are all non-fiction books the
best of all these books is this little
black one right here
it's so good i got a few of them got a
few of them really good book this orange
one's good as well i've got loads of
these orange ones because they're so
good
the best but yeah so
if you are poor minded right now okay if
you're thinking man i do bash rich
people
man i usually bash samuel leads i'm on
his youtube every day
um i don't value my time and i do work
hard
and i do often say i'd rather be happy
and i do find myself
watching school friends that are
becoming more successful than me hoping
that they'll not
get a promotion because it will make me
feel bad and i do complain a lot
and i am pretty entitled and uh yeah i
do invest my money in junk
and i think i probably do love money and
i do value entertainment i watch more
netflix than i do watching seminars and
reading books
um i i guess the first thing is respect
just for being on this call
respect for watching my youtube channel
and um
you have a choice you know you can just
choose to flick that
you can say you know what from now on
i'm going to value my time i'm going to
start respecting rich people
i'm going to start working smart and i'm
going to educate myself to learn how to
work smart
and i'm not going to ever say i'd rather
just be happy
i'm going to acknowledge and accept that
i can have it all i can have my health
my wealth
my family my business my finance my
spiritual i can have it all
and as soon as i accept that i can have
it all then something i've got no i
can't make excuses anymore because now
i've got to go get it
and i'm going to see the best in people
i'm not going to complain about things
i'm not going to expect anything for
free but i'm going to work for things
and i'm going to give value and i'm
going to serve people i'm going to start
investing my money in my business and in
myself and in things that are going to
give me a passive income
and i'm going to use money instead of
loving money
and i'm gonna value education i'm gonna
start learning more because the more i
learn the more i earn and the bigger i
grow
you know you can really choose that that
can be a choice
so anyway i'm gonna wrap up in a minute
are rich people worry that their
children might blow up everything they
have built up
i don't i don't think so no because
because rich people
it's being rich starts with a mindset
you know
so it's not like you just inherited the
money and you're like oh my gosh i'm
scared i'm going to lose it and i'm
scared the kids are going to be like no
i'm rich but
i mean i'm not i'm not worried about
losing it because if i lose it i'll go
get it again
there's no problem it's like uh you've
got food in the cupboard so you're
worried that the food's going to go no
you're not worried because you just go
back to the shop and get it
you know where to get it from and in the
same way i know where to go get money i
know how to make money
i know how to i just know what to do uh
if you've got any more as well let me
know
just don't give up that's it nothing
more it says to be property
respect to be property uh yeah there's
so many that's just ten but there's
probably there's probably a thousand
and i would suggest studying this
studying rich people
also another thing rich people tend to
do is
um is when rich people are watching
youtube videos that they really like
they tend to they tend to press
like you know i heard that i don't know
if it's true
but i heard that they tend to press like
when they're watching videos so
if you're watching this video please do
me a big favor and smash like
um i think that's the 11th that's the i
can see i can see the lights going up
now i appreciate that
i really do appreciate that um our lease
option agreement's a hoax someone keeps
saying no they are not
they are not a hoax these options
agreements are a very real thing
um so yeah oh 53 likes
that's what rich people do man rich
people smash the like button and i've
heard that i've heard that losers
losers smash the dislike button so if i
see dislikes i just i just i just feel
really bad for you i'll be like oh man
i'd be like it sucks what would you go
on a video that you hate so badly and
keep watching it over and over
i take up so much space in people's
brains sometime
some of some of the haters okay would
you do the financially free challenge
with a young person as
young people are not respected because
of their age yeah i probably would i
probably would
i'm sure i'll do the financial freedom
challenge again one day
guys i hope you enjoyed the video um if
you can think of any other reasons and
different different things that
differentiate
i'm struggling now rich people and poor
people
that i haven't said put it in the
comments below i'd love to hear
winners love winners that is so true
winners love winners i believe that and
winners love to see people winning
losers do not like to see people winning
so i hope this helped
thank you for watching the video respect
a lot of love from me
to you and tomorrow i'm doing a q a
sunday video so if you want if you've
got technical questions around property
investment
tax rent to rent hmos anything like that
then um
jump on tomorrow's video and i'll be
there at 7 00 pm it's not gonna be live
i'm gonna film it at about five o'clock
and then i'm going to bank it out for
7pm
all right guys i'll see you real soon
thanks for watching subscribe as well
subscribe as well i forgot to say that
number 12
rich people subscribe to youtube
channels that they like
yeah subscribe to the channel i really
appreciate that thanks for all the
comments thanks for the love thanks for
the support tyrone you're the man
the helpful entrepreneur thank you and
uh yeah so please do subscribe
i would appreciate that um and i'll see
you guys tomorrow
peace out